now here with more co-host of the hit
show The Five our great friend judge
Janine Piro the one and only judge uh
put on your legal hat for a minute here
and let's look at at Joe Biden himself
in all of this and the amount of money
if it wasn't for Joe Biden none of this
money would be coming in what are your
thoughts how does this get back to him
well first of all the amazing we have to
understand that this is an indictment
where by the same guy who tried to pull
the wool over everybody's eyes and
literally take this case for a plea
negotiation into a court where a judge
said hey wait a minute has the
Department of Justice ever done this
before and they had to reach back and
say no we've never done it before they
were trying to hide tax charges in a
plea agreement involving a gun for which
Hunter at that point wasn't even charged
so if you think there's anything on the
straight and narrow the up and up about
this indictment you're wrong the only
thing about this indictment it's it's
nothing more than what we've heard about
we already knew that he was someone who
was involved with hookers and whes and
all kinds of human trafficking and all
kinds of money spent on exotic cars
hotels and rental properties but this
new indictment doesn't say much more
than what we already knew what's missing
and no surprises they tried to get away
with a good with a plea deal of the
century says nothing about for his being
a foreign agent it says nothing about
human trafficking nothing about money
laundering and Joe Biden is involved in
this and I'll tell you how Hunter Biden
is profiting off of his father's name we
know from balinsky Devin Archer that
there were meetings at that cafe Marmont
or whatever it is in Los Angeles we know
that there are 327 emails where Joe
Biden is using a pseudonym directly in
contact with uh Eric scherwin because
they're talking about business and we've
got emails that are occurring ex exactly
at the time when the Ukrainian deal is
going down and Joe Biden goes over there
and says if you don't uh get rid of the
prosecutor on this company my son's on
you're not getting a billion dollars in
American money that is corruption per se
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else